bonjour bienvenue sur les plateformes du
figaro pour évoquer l'actualité et vos
points de vue sur celle-ci et quand je
dis vos points de vue je pense à vous
qui nous suivait sur internet et sur les
réseaux sociaux mais aussi à mes deux
invités de ce vendredi 4 septembre
tout d'abord ferghana ziari jeunes
mariés mais aussi et surtout analyste en
politiques publiques à l'institut de
recherche économique et de la
concurrence fiscale l'iref et délégué
général de l'académie libre des sciences
humaines on peut aussi lire vos analyses
empreinte de convictions libérales sur
le figaro vox face à vous moins libérale
que conservateur assumer guillaume
bernard maître de conférences à
l'institut catholique d'études
supérieures de vendée à la roche sur yon
auteur notamment d'un livre dont le
titre me paraît toujours d'actualité la
guerre à droite aura bien lieu le
mouvement dextrogyre chez des clés
brewer on en reparlera en deuxième
partie d'émission sur quoi allez-vous
débattre avant et peut-être vous discuté
et bien d'abord sur ce discours assez
flamboyant d'emmanuel macron ce matin à
l'occasion de la cérémonie célébrant le
150e anniversaire de la proclamation de
la république le 4 septembre 1870 après
la défaite de sedan et la chute de
napoléon iii le président de la
république a profité de l'occasion pour
rappeler avec beaucoup de force les
valeurs de ce qu'on peut appeler le
patriotisme républicain appelant
notamment à lutter contre les
séparatismes qui menacent notre système
mais il ya parfois loin des paroles aux
actes et je vous demanderais si vous
pensez que ce discours relève de la
communication politique ou peut
effectivement déboucher sur des actes
forts nous nous rendrons ensuite
virtuellement dans une ville qui elle
fleure bon plus tôt l'ancien régime
le port marly ce qui n'a pas empêché les
républicains de choisir cette commune
des yvelines pour organiser leur réunion
de rentrée autour de leurs jeunes afin
de préparer la campagne présidentielle
de 2022 avez vous l'impression qu'il ait
l'air affirme d'ores et déjà une ligne
claire dans cette optique c'est la
question que je vous poserai et à
laquelle les internautes sont invités à
répondre durant toute l'émission sur le
site du figaro on commence tout d'abord
donc avec ce discours d' emmanuel macron
ce matin au panthéon discours très
lyrique très enlevé très ambitieux dont
je vous propose d'ailleurs d'entendre un
petit extrait ans écrivait marc bloch et
la patrie dont je ne saurais déracinés
mon coeur j'ai bu aux sources de sa
culture j'ai fait mien sont passées je
ne respire bien que sous son ciel et je
me suis efforcé à mon tour de la
défendre de mon mieux
c'est tout cela entrée en république
française et met nos paysages notre
histoire notre culture en bloque
toujours alors ce discours nous inspirer
cette interrogation que nous soumettons
votre réflexion sur twitter ce
patriotisme républicain que célèbre
emmanuel macron ne se résume t-il pas
qu'à des paroles fusse-t-elle de belles
paroles vous même guillaume permanent
guillaume bernard quand pensez vous et
surtout est-ce que vous avez un peu
vibrer à ce discours en préalable
c'est une provocation forme cette
question évidemment je trouve emmanuel
macron de plus en plus sirupeux et
exaspérant je crois qu'il ya quand même
beaucoup de choses à dire sur d'abord le
choix de la date
la proclamation de la république alors
il répond ce haut parleur est mieux de
ça que moi un grand messe du second
empire et de début de tournoi exactement
mais enfin quand même proclamé la
république quand l'occupant prussiens et
là qui en profitera d'ailleurs pour
proclamer le soi-disant second empire
allemand dans la galerie des glaces à
versailles
je trouve ça extrêmement maladroit et
donc on le sait bien de toute façon pris
ma tendance des impôts c'est lorsque
pompidou l'afl en 1970 se doit même
façon oui mais je l'aurais pas fait leur
place voilà simplement juste que je suis
la corde avec mon point de vue au moins
les choses sont claires
non on le sait bien de toute façon la
troisième république c'est l'amendement
wallon en 75 et puis les trois lois les
trois lois de 2 février juillet 75 qui
suivent le 4 septembre 70 et une
proclamation symbolique banc ensuite il
est évident que là nous sommes au coeur
d'un vrai débat de philosophie politique
essentielle c'est qu'est ce que c'est
que la république et qu'est ce que c'est
que la france et quelle est
l'articulation entre les deux emmanuel
macron continue
défendre et en cela il est cohérent
l'idée que dans le fond le corps social
c'est le contrat social dans le fond ils
privilégient le régime politique au
corps social dans sa continuité
historique
j'en suis désolé la république a
peut-être 150 ans mais la france elle a
mille cinq cents ans pendant que des
entités et donc par conséquent je crois
que le régime politique quel qu'il soit
je peux avoir des préférences pour l'un
ou pour un autre mais enfin en tout cas
le régime politique doit d'être au
service du corps social et pâle inverse
et je crois pas qu'il se donne les
moyens véritablement lutter mais je
suppose qu'on va en reparler de lutter
véritablement contre le séparatisme
ferghana ce que vous êtes aussi sévères
ont l'impression tout ça est très
théorique ne débouche finalement sur
rien de concret c'est assez théorique et
la télé je reçois un jour je rejoins
pardon il dit au ghana quand il dit
effectivement que en soit la formule de
patriotisme républicain c'est une
formule assez creuse médias que la
république qu'est ce que ça ce n'est
qu'un vulliet régime politiste un
système institutionnel c'est pas une fin
en soi
moi je ne suis pas quelqu'un qui exalte
la vème république en tant que système
politique en tant qu'institution encore
faut-il définir les valeurs que que
servent les institutions aujourd'hui et
là dessus si là où il ya un flou parce
que bon une fois que vous dites que vous
êtes républicain vous n'avez encore rien
dit est ce que vous êtes un républicain
des points les plus conservatrices
libérales social démocrate socialiste
écologiste islamique ou que sais-je
encore bon donc tout ça ne veut pas dire
grand chose là où j'ai un petit peu déçu
c'est peut-être sur le côté un peu
historique mais j'aurais voulu qu'il
fasse aussi le bilan de la république
française puisque aujourd'hui nos
institutions sont en perte de vitesse
sur le pour la légitimité il ya une
espèce de délitement de d d d d
allégeance vis-à-vis des institutions
françaises et des objections aussi
qu'ils sont tout à fait je crois valable
et auquel il n'a pas répondu
quid de la qualité de ce système est il
aussi démocratique qu'on le prétend
aujourd'hui comment peut-il faire pour
répondre aux enjeux d'aujourd'hui est ce
qu'il n'ya pas des remises en question
je n'ai pas vu de ces temps de remise en
question
on voit emmanuel macron comme ça qui
tient des paroles un peu qui est sur une
posture un peu triomphaliste voilà la
république elle est là et puis il faut
s'en féliciter il ya aussi des critiques
peut-être à apporter à ce système
puisque la cinquième subi pas mal de
critiques et là dessus c'est vrai que je
n'ai pas vu de bilan suffisamment
critique et j'aurais aimé qu'il y ait un
bilan plus critique et ensuite on
reviendra sur des faits des paroles
qu'il a prononcées sur séparatistes
entre autres choses je me fais un peu
l'avocat de dia mais justement pour lui
la république c'est ce site de ce
système qui permet dé léon gambetta des
marie curie dé gisèle halimi des félix
éboué qui va rejoindre le général de
gaulle et justement les citer tous et
non pour dire c'est la république qui a
permis tous ces gens d'émerger et de
faire de faire la france
oui et en même temps on peut aussi dire
aujourd'hui que je vais la république en
tant que qu'institution dont on parle
beaucoup des défauts table on sort de la
crise et gilet jaune et qui à me
replonger
oui on risque de plonger aussi donc qui
a quand même mis en lumière pas mal
d'obstacles d' entrave un sentiment
d'injustice qui prévaut et qui parfois
est donc imputer aussi à certaines
lourdeurs de lourdeur de ce système dit
républicain on a beaucoup parlé de la
suisse par exemple pendant les gilet
jaune on n'a pas suffisamment souligné
le fait que un tel pays a réussi à
atteindre un consensus social quand même
inégalée grâce à des grâces à ses
appartements cette décentralisation là
où notre système gangréné par le
jacobinisme pour moi ne crée que de la
discorde
donc toi toutes ces problématiques là
qui ont été soulevées ces dix derniers
mois à force de crises répétées n'ont
pas été mis sur la table et c'est en ce
sens que j'ai été aussi un peu déçu par
ce discours je vais vous faire réagir
sur une autre partie de son discours qui
m'a semblé assez intéressant et coûteuse
le sacre de reims et la fête de la
fédération c'est pour cela que la
république ne déboulonne pas de statut
ne choisit pas simplement une part de
son histoire car on ne choisit jamais
une part de france ont choisi la france
la lhjmq bernard vous vous le trouvez
n'ont toujours pas votre beau parce
qu'il sait du hong kong et assume toute
la france y compris les taches sombres
dans l'histoire de france ne vous donne
pas les statuts alors qu on déboulonne
pas les statuts dans mieux évidemment
mais
c'est dû en même temps contradictoires
encore une fois on ne sait pas
véritablement ce qu'il met sous le terme
de république si vous lisiez les
hauteurs de l'ancienne france on sait
très bien que la monarchie était une
république était une res publica au sens
de la chose publique de la défense du
bien commun
or là c'est un courant idéologique et
qui essayent docu de d'assoir un
monopole sur une notion dont ils n'ont
pas à mon sens véritablement le monopole
quant à la question de savoir si
effectivement il faut prendre tout de
l'histoire c'est une telle évidence que
qui leur disent tant mieux mais sinon ça
ne prouve rien vous êtes sur la même
ligne fergane pas pas vraiment réalité
qu'il faille de tout prendre au sens qui
ne faut pas nier ce qui s'est passé
notre histoire évidemment mais on peut
aussi choisir les récits que l'on veut
valoriser donc je vois qu'il fait
référence effectivement cette vague un
peu iconoclaste qui a qui a déversé ont
d'ailleurs profité et qui dure en effet
encore de moi je ne suis pas insensible
à ce mouvement qui consiste à je suis
pas insensible à cette volonté de
challenger un peu le récit national et à
ce qu'il ya faire part de nos objections
sur ce qu'on décide de valoriser ou non
quand on quand on dit qu'on assume tout
ça ne veut pas dire qu'on valorise tout
au risque d'atteindre rapidement le
point godwin chez elle oui mais et des
épisodes que l'on valorise pas il n'y a
pas de statut de pétain sur la place
publique pour une bonne raison il n'y a
pas de deux statues de telle ou telle
figure controversée donc fermer le débat
si vous voulez aussi aussi radicale et
et refuser qu'on puisse remettre en
question certains aspects de l'épopée
nationale ne me semble pas une démarche
une démarche intelligente je pense que
c'est une
c'est une démarche légitime que de
démettre ses objections là alors cette
cérémonie avait surtout pour objet de
pointer un problème majeur de la
république française aujourd'hui
je vous propose d'écouter ce qu'il en a
dit sur ce sujet du séparatisme
il n'y aura jamais de place en france
pour ceux qui souvent au nom d'un dieu
parfois avec l'aide de puissances
étrangères entendent imposer la loi d'un
groupe non la république parce qu'elle
est indivisible n'a mené aucune aventure
séparatiste alors avant de vous faire
réagir sur cette partie de son discours
la question twitter était le patriotisme
républicain célébré par emmanuel macron
ne se résume t-il pas qu'à des paroles
ce n'est pas un hasard si je vous pose
cette question à ce moment là mais la
réponse est oui à 60 8% ne se résume
qu'à des paroles et non à 30 2%
guillaume bernard c'est ça qui menace le
plus sa société aujourd'hui le les
séparatismes c'est l'atomisation de la
société elle est due effectivement à un
séparatisme venu je dirais de cultures
étrangères
elle est due aussi malheureusement
déracinement des français eux-mêmes à
des français d'origines ce même moi je
crois qu'il ne se donne évidemment pas
les moyens de lutter contre ce
séparatisme
parce que ça nécessiterait d'affirmer
l'existence d'une identité française que
ceux qui sont d'origine étrangère s'il
ya 6000 et que dans le cas où il
refuserait de 6 assimilés et bien qu'ils
repartent
c'est l'assimilation la remise gracieuse
donc il est bien évident qu'à partir du
moment où il admet le multiculturalisme
il ya aucune raison que les séparatismes
ne se met pas en place
parce que j'ai l'impression que quand il
dit séparatisme ils pensent séparatisme
désiste de l'islam des musulmans sans le
dire parce qu'il yad'autres commises
comme séparatisme c'est une très bonne
question je pense que le discours de
mulhouse par don d'agacer le disco c'est
bis repetita le discours de mulhouse
avant le confinement
je pense que le mot séparatisme est très
mal choisi et finalement rang rome
ne rend pas ce fut assez bien la réalité
de la menace et des risques qui pèsent
aujourd'hui sur l'ordre public
le séparatisme c'est une notion vague
qui peut recouvrir de multiples réalités
parfois et qu'elles peuvent parfois être
totalement pacifique
si nous étions face à des gens qui
aspirent à imiter des amish aux états
unis nous n'aurions pas les problèmes
sécuritaires que nous avons aujourd'hui
en réalité ce mot séparatisme c'est une
espèce de diversion pour ne pas avoir
employé le terme d'impérialisme ou
d'autoritarisme de totalitarisme
islamique puisque c'est bien ce cette
religion et cette idéologie qui
télévisée donc l'impression que par les
séparatistes c'est un peu botté en
touche aussi c'est à dire que en soit
encore une fois aux yeux de l'union
européenne les britanniques sont des
séparatistes et c'est pas ça qui va
menacer la paix civile en europe
les corses ont de ce port louis donc
donc les séparatismes peuvent être tout
à fait bienveillant et pacifique donc là
n'est pas vraiment le bon terme je pense
que pour rendre compte du véritable
danger qui pèse sur sur une société il
faut évoquer le caractère
potentiellement criminogène de
l'idéologie ici en cause donc employer
des termes qui rendre compte du
caractère totalitaire du phénomène chi
chi chi auxquels on fait face
aujourd'hui
et là-dessus effectivement on aurait
aimé qu'il soit plus explicite
nicole surre lefilm.fr n'y a t'il des
actes contre les séparatismes
aujourd'hui c'est une bonne question
parce que c'est un peu le sens de ce
débat c'est on a des belles paroles on
est tous d'accord avec ce qu'il vient de
dire mais est ce que concrètement un
sentiment qu'est une volonté de lutter
contre ces séparatistes et celui dont on
en parle j'ai pas la pression la seule
chose qu'il a qu'il est véritablement
annoncé c'est que les associés me
semble-t-il c'est que les associations
qui recevraient des subventions je ne
savais pas qu'il y avait des six
associations islamistes qui recevait des
subventions ça va mieux par le biais de
centre cultuel du bain culturel
justement mini sont des centres
culturels que les associations qui
reçoivent des subventions devraient
signer une charte des valeurs
républicaines et c'est là où évidemment
on retombe dans le flou c'est qu'elles
sont ces valeurs quelles sont ces
valeurs républicaines est ce que c'est
l'identité du corps social
ou est ce que c'est à la verse
simplement des principes juridiques
c'est ça le fond du problème est ce que
vous n'avez pas l'impression qu'il ya
quand même un peu évolué parce qu'on
sent bien que dans son discours contre
les séparatismes ce séparatisme dont on
parle il n'y a qu'une arme à six
dispositions qui est la laïcité
or au tout début de son quinquennat il
me semblait que sur la licité été assez
prudent il était même en fait un
discours pour dénoncer les laïcistes est
aujourd'hui peut-être sous l'influencé
de jean michel blanquer on a le
sentiment parce que c'est aussi parce
qu'elle procès charlie en ce moment que
la laïcité est devenu le le larmes
fatale pour lutter contre le séparatisme
en l'occurrence d'islamique moi je pense
je ne pense même pas que ce soit une
question de laïcité une fille née parce
que la laïcité ce n'est que la
séparation des églises et de l'état mais
ça ne dit absolument rien quand on dire
du danger des idéologies qui peuvent
traverser la société civile donc on est
là face à une question plus culturelle
qu une question juridique à la laïcité
c'est une question juridique qui ne
concerne que l'état en tant
qu'institution et ses rapports avec les
différents cultes qui peuvent relancer
la société
ici on est face à une religion à une
idéologie politico-religieuse en effet
qui pose donc un véritable danger pour
le pluralisme légalité des libertés donc
l'énorme civilisationnel occidental donc
c'est une question culturelle qui est
bien plus profonde que celle de la
laïcité
or là dessus je ne suis pas certain que
finalement ce soir emmanuel macron de
mener ce combat je pense que c'est un
combat qui tue culturel qui relève des
médias qui relève des intellectuels des
commentateurs qui relève finalement de
la société civile à condition de bien
nommé l'ennemi et à condition d'être des
complexes et aussi à l'idée d'assumer
que non toutes les religions ne se
valent pas que que certaines religions
et en particulier en particulier l'islam
peuvent se révéler problématique est
incompatible avec nos normes
civilisationnel et des principes de
justice que qu'on affectionne
le problème aujourd'hui c'est qu'il ya
encore une trop grande frilosité
c'est-à-dire un complexe post coloniale
qui nous interdit de critiquer de
remettre en question voire de
hiérarchiser austin de les religions en
fonction de leurs qualités respectives
et ça c'est pas emmanuel macron qui va
mener ce combat c'est un travail que
nous
mené nous en tant que société civile je
terminais avec vous guillaume bernard et
cette réflexion de alex lefigaro.fr qui
me semble très intéressante
multiculturalisme d'un côté vent
girondins de l'autre souveraineté
européenne la république n'était pas
abîmée par ses positions du président
qui fait du en même temps et qui bien
sûr et c'est ce que dit ferghana
l'instant et je suis parfaitement
d'accord c'est l'indifférentisme l'état
prétend faire de l'indifférentisme
culturel et du coup il se réduit à
l'impuissance face à des mouvements
sociaux qui évidemment ont une ambition
impérialistes oui en tout cas nos
internautes restent sur leur idée que le
patriotisme républicain célébré par
emmanuel macron se résume surtout à des
paroles puissent ils sont restés à 68 %
à considérer cela ainsi on passe au
second débat du jour
aujourd'hui et demain les républicains
se réunissent au port-marly lors d'une
réunion de rentrée mettant en avant les
jeunes des républicains problème entre
les amis de bruno retailleau qui se sont
déjà réunis la semaine dernière à la
baule et le pavé macro ni un dans la
mare lancé cette semaine dans le figaro
par christian estrosi
sans oublier le silence obstiné de
françois baroin et les ambitions
affirmées de xavier bertrand ou de
valérie pécresse qui en dehors des
structures à l'air peuvent attirer des
cadres ou des militants de droite on est
en droit de se demander et c'est notre
deuxième question du jour
si les républicains affirment une ligne
claire pour 2022
j'ai regardé ce que l'impression qu' une
ligne claire celle des républicains en
ce moment alors je pense que même une
saveur si vous me demandez quelles sont
les valeurs les positions les
propositions des républicains je serais
incapable de vous les donner mais je
pense que eux mêmes seraient pas
capables de de se définir en tant qu' en
tant que courant idéologique pour la
simple et bonne raison que la droite
française
en réalité pêche par le fait qu'elle n'a
jamais vraiment eu de colonne vertébrale
idéologique et il me semble qu'elle a
toujours été un peu embarrassé par son
héritage gaulliste son héritage gaullien
or le général de gaulle se vantait
justement vantait le fait que le
gaullisme n'est pas une doctrine n'était
pas une idéologie
inoki assez de volonté un peu artificiel
mais toujours vaines de se situer en
dehors des clivages le gobelet de métro
à 18 heures donc beaucoup de monde voilà
c'est ça et donc aujourd'hui se dire
gaulliste qui restent encore je crois le
petit dénominateur commun de ces gens là
ça ne veut pas dire grand chose à se
dire mondial s'est terminée la guerre
d'algérie s'est terminée aussi donc de
ce point de vue là le gaullisme on n'a
plus vraiment besoin
problème c'est que ce mouvement ne sait
pas comment se définir alors il est un
peu prise en étau entre 1 emmanuel
macron qui au début a tenu un discours
un peu libérale même si dans les faits
fait-il mans il ya un gouffre je
reviendrai c'est beau de toute façon
jamais assez pour moi mais je pense pas
du tout vrai si l'on volé les grands
indicateurs économiques en france
et puis il ya une espèce de 2 tentation
aussi effectivement d'aller vers un
conservatisme un peu plus autoritaire
organiciste qui lui davantage incarné
par le rn mais je sais pas comment ils
vont se différencier dans la mesure où
un espace pour un vrai libéralisme et
ils savent très bien qu'en france c'est
pour l'instant de mission impossible ce
serait suicidaire donc ils vont
l'exclure ça c'est ça c'est certain mais
en l'absence de cette option là je ne
vois pas comment ils arriveront à se
différencier d'un consensus social
démocrate un peu mou incarné par
emmanuel macron et un conservatisme un
nationaliste un peu plus autoritaire
incarné par le rassemblement national
guillaume bernard hinault de richesse
que d'hommes comme disait jean bodin que
vous connaissez bien votre don vous
connaissez bien l'oeuvre
justement est ce que la droite se résume
ce n'est pas toujours le même débat
est-ce qu'il faut d'abord un programme
ou un homme ou une femme et le programme
il s'agrègent ensuite est-ce qu'on n'est
pas au coeur de ceux de ce sujet qui est
vu comme la droite je vais dire parce
que il a fallu des points car aider
tardieu ou des de gaulle pour incarner
ou des sarkozy peut être avec des
illusions à la fin mai en fait la droite
ne se rassemblent que lorsqu'elle a
quelqu'un pour l'incarner aujourd'hui on
a une pléthore de candidats potentiels
ou est-ce qu'il faut quand même d'abord
un programme en espérant que quelqu'un
incarnera ce programme c'est une
excellente question est très délicate
vous avez évoqué différents types de
personnalités actuelles et passées
je crains tu le niveau n'est que baisser
bon bien sûr qu'il faut une incarnation
et bien sûr que psychologiquement la
droite est quand même plutôt porté à
vouloir un chef et un chef naturel
le problème c'est qu'il n'y en a pas et
vous dites vous même qu'il faut d'abord
un chef avant d'avoir ne dis pas qu'il
faut d'abord un chef je dis que lorsque
le corps social à vis de manière
naturelle des traditions des coutumes
le programme politique il est je dirais
presque
il est presque évident est d'ailleurs un
programme mais alors là je m'écarte de
votre réponse mais le programme
j'allais dire comme un de ceux qui est
véritablement de droite et pas
simplement à droite il existe un an
l'autorité l'identité la souveraineté
les libertés et la dignité
ça tient en cinq mots et ça rassemble 80
% de l'électorat aussi bien de l air que
que du rassemblement national
non je crois que malheureusement c'est
parce qu'il n'ya aucune ligne directrice
que malheureusement ces personnalités
politiques ont pris l'habitude je dirais
de raisonner de manière court termiste
en terme uniquement d'élections et non
pas en termes d'objectifs et de mettre
des moyens au service des objectifs
qu'ils n'ont pas de doctrine qu'ils
n'ont pas véritablement du coup de
programme et que eh bien simplement les
questions de personnes deviennent
deviennent prévalente moi je crois que
les partis politiques notamment due au
phénomène macron mais que les partis
politiques tels qu'ils existaient avant
donc 2017 et bien sont en fin de règne
que ce soit le rassemblement national
qui dans quelques jours à savoir s'il
est ou non mis en liquidation judiciaire
et
heller qui fait semblant de croire qu'il
existe encore alors qu'à l'évidence il
ya toute une partie de l'électorat qui
est parti chez makro qui a tous une
autre partie celle qui a voté un bel ami
il ne sait pas où elle est il est bien
évident que la recomposition du spectre
politique est absolument non seulement
inéluctable mais même nécessaire et que
cette recomposition
elle passe par différentes choses bien
sûr la fin du cordon sanitaire vis-à-vis
du rassemblement national mais aussi la
réorganisation et des élus et des
électeurs au delà même des actuels
partis tels qu'ils existent sur la base
d'un programme commun tels manger puis
en parlait il ya quelques minutes
allemand il ya quand même l'absolu mais
je vous propose quand même d'écouter
damien abad qui est président du groupe
et l'air à l'assemblée nationale qui est
au top du figaro lui a quand même
certitude sur ce qu'est la droite est ce
qu'elle est aujourd'hui
il ya aussi beaucoup d'électeurs de
droite et de français qui pensent qu'il
faut une alternative au duel macron le
pen que les français ne veulent pas moi
je pense qu'il ya une erreur d'analysé
c'est de considérer que parce qu'on va
fondre les républicains dans le
maquereau nisme on va pouvoir finalement
assuré la victoire à l'élection
présidentielle
je pense qu'au contraire il ya un grand
danger c'est laisser un espace politique
vide en faveur de madame le pen et moi
je pense que la droite doit arrêter de
regarder ses voisins elle doit s'occuper
d'elle-même et reconquérir les coeurs et
le discours devient d'abord avec un
discours sur la question de l'autorité
du régalien de l'état de droit de la
sécurité la suivante à emmanuel macron
qui manque clairement emmanuel macron
voc le maquereau nisme cdu en même temps
c'est du nihilisme en matière de
sécurité et c'est l'inaction de la
paralysie s'organiser le sentiment que l
heure est quand même bloqué par par
l'ombre de emmanuel macron dont je
pensais sont bloqués par leur manque
d'imagination parce qu'encore une fois
emmanuel macron alors il s'éteint c'est
quelqu'un qui a toujours rêvé de
dépolitisation et de dépassement des
clivages mais la réalité il incarne
plutôt une espèce de tradition saint
simonienne technocratique jacobine donc
il ya eu quand même qu'on le veuille ou
non une espèce de deux courants de
pensée alors qu'ils y se veut enfin qui
n'est pas toujours conscients de
lui-même et on pourrait toujours opposé
à au saint simonisme un autre projet
politique plein de courants
intellectuels concurrents qui peuvent
peut très bien opposer le giron dix mots
jacobine y sont peu un peu on peut
opposer
la décentralisation hausse au
centralisme le libéralisme au saint
simonisme donc il ya plein de courant
comme ça qu'on pourrait opposer emmanuel
macron la réalité c'est que chez l ère
chez da droit de manière générale il ya
des tendances aussi irréconciliables
c'est à dire va-t-on dépasser ce fameux
clivage de rené rémond entre cette
fameuse droite orléaniste bonapartiste
ou légitime je ne sais quoi la réalité
c'est que un moment il va falloir
clarifier à mon avis définir le fait que
toutes les droites ne peuvent pas se
fondre dans un même moule
et là dessus je pense que tant que la
droite n'aura pas clarifié ces clivages
internes
elle n'arrivera jamais à se définir et à
projeter à se projeter dans la vie
politique et idéologique française est
d'ailleurs alex son fils au point fr
tout à fait d'accord avec vous puisque
il dit entre retailleau qui est un
deuxième fillon baroin le progressiste
libéral girondins et obère le
souverainiste où est le dénominateur
commun est ce que le dénominateur commun
ça peut quand même pas être baroin
fédérera tous ces gens le plus récent le
plus belles villes teaser demain oui
c'est pas comme ça que vous accédez au
second tour moi je crois qu'il commette
deux et c'est la question du jour qu'on
demande à ceux qui parce qu'il sera
candidat à votre avis est ce qui brille
avec paroisse soit baroin je n'en sais
strictement rien je ne suis pas dans les
arcanes du parti je ne peux pas le
savoir mais je crois que s'ils cherchent
à avoir un candidat si heller cherchent
à avoir un candidat que ce soit baroin
ou retailleau dans le but de de comment
dire d'être obsédé par le cas de marine
le pen dont on ne sait d'ailleurs pas si
elle pourra véritablement ou non être
candidate
même si elle s'est déclarée eh bien ils
commettent une erreur quand on regarde
l'état de l'opinion lorsque l'on
présente en aveugle c'est-à-dire sans
étiquette politique
les propositions des mesures les mesures
de droite sont ultra majoritaires en
france
autrement dit la campagne pour la
présidentielle de 2002 elle ne doit pas
être pensé en termes qui va prendre la
place marine le pen face à macro mais
qui va prendre la place de macron
comment prendre la place de macron et
c'est ça qui me semble essentiel
deuxième erreur il me semble qu'ils font
aux républicains c'est qu'ils essayent à
tout
i de vouloir faire le mariage à carpe et
du lapin en essayant d'associer le
libéralisme et le conservatisme
or où le conservatisme et le faux nez du
libéralisme et dans ce cas-là ça sert à
rien de se dire conservateurs ou à la
verse le conservatisme est l'antichambre
de la pensée classique de la pensée on
va dire entre guillemets réactionnaire
et dans ce cas là effectivement il me
semble qu'il ya un espace politique
c'est là on ne sommes pas d'accord avec
fergane c'est que lui voile me
semble-t-il le libéralisme en tant que
système économique alors que je pense
que le libéralisme est en fait une
pensée philosophie su philosophie
pendant subjectiviste et qui fait qu' il
n'a pas le libéralisme nos paul de la
lutte contre le fiscalisme de la lutte
contre la sur administration le mammouth
et c'est donc je crois que l air devrait
n'ont pas résonné
ils ne peuvent plus raisonner en tant
que parti politique il faut raisonner en
termes de dynamique en termes de courant
il pourrait très bien y avoir ce n'est
qu'une proposition je ne dis pas que
c'est une bonne proposition mais une
primaire de la droite de la vraie droite
de ce qui est véritablement deux droites
et pas de ce qui est simplement à droite
primaire dans laquelle il pourrait y
avoir
jean frédéric poisson philippe de
villiers à manuel r et pourquoi pas même
des gens issus du rassemblement national
et dans ce cas là effectivement cette
droite là recomposée pourrait désigner
un candidat qui serait adoubé par au
moins un tiers des lectorats dès le
premier tour
juste pour répondre quand même pour ma
part je ne crois pas que le libéral
c'est tout un système économique c'est
avant tout une philosophie du droit
c'est la vie c'est la philosophie du
droit de propriété lotfi de la libre
disposition de soin de son corps
bon et en soit cette philosophie ciblé
n'est pas vraiment incompatibles avec
des valeurs traditionnelles et la droite
anglo saxon britannique arrive
à marier la liberté avec l'idée qu'en
revanche les valeurs traditionnelles
doivent être défendus par la société
civile avant avant toute chose et non
pas par l'état il me semble que vous
vous représentez plutôt une espèce de
conservatisme autoritaire par lequel
donc ses valeurs traditionnelles doivent
être administrées par des fonctionnaires
il me semble ça ne s'est pas sa part
n'est pas mon cas c'est ce que je veux
dire c'est que on l'a on a une
présentation assez nette du le clivage
au sein de la droite puisque guillaume
dernière fait partie de ceux qui veulent
complètement évacué le libéralisme mais
qui s'appelle candidat albert droite
aujourd'hui flammes j'ai juste besoin
qu'il incarnerait nain politique dont je
pense que c'est complètement irréaliste
aujourd'hui de raisonner en termes de
candidature parce que le libéralisme n'a
pas encore une fois n'a pas eu n'a pas
gagné sa bataille culturelle est donc
temps que culturellement la france sera
allergique au libéralisme ce n'est même
pas la peine d'envisager qu'un
politicien de gauche ou de droite
d'ailleurs parce que moi je ne suis pas
forcément convaincu que le libéralisme
ne soit un monopole de droite concernant
l'êta tissant des fleuves et réalisme
sont deux courants qui transcende les
clivages traditionnels reconnaît que
benjamin constant et à la fois
considérable de gauche frédéric bastiat
cga gauge l'assemblée nationale assure
jacques bien eu lieu entre l'as
libéralisme comme étant à des courants
de gauche bien sûr donc là dessus donc
mais encore une fois je pense que tant
qu'il n'aura pas clarifié en effet le
rapport que la droite entretient avec
tous ces courants là elle n'ira pas bien
loin
et alors vous avez raison pardon fergane
sur un point c'est que évidemment il ya
ce qu'on appelle des droites
sauf qu'il ya des droites qui sont comme
le disait frédéric bruch cette fois ci
c'est un autre spécialiste mais lui
plutôt du premier empire
il ya des droites qui en fait étaient
les centres au xixème siècle et ont
glissé vers la droite mais ne sont pas
ont péri ta ble ment de droite ou en
tout cas qu'il soit libéral ou
progressistes ou conservateurs françois
baroin selon nos internautes à 75 % ne
sera pas candidat à l'élection
présidentielle je ne suis pas sûr que ça
fera beaucoup de gens malheureux sur ce
plateau 67% d'ailleurs même en tout cas
merci à tous les deux
orange vous donne rendez-vous lundi pour
un nouveau point de vue sans moi mais
toujours sur le fil au point fr d'ici là
je ne saurais trop vous conseiller de
lire le figaro magazine de ce week-end
consacré aux folies des mr écolo leur
obsession leur idéologie leurs dégâts
l'enfer de la circulation à paris qui
concerne les parisiens légende ile de
france et ceux qui viennent de province
qui en voiture qu'ils s'en rendent
compte
en tout cas c'est une belle lecture que
je vous conseille vivement bonsoir